hey what's up everybody welcome to the
corridor cast right now it's actually
just me just me and my friend addie
shankar
welcome maddie
uh dude
so good to see you man it's good to see
you too i haven't seen you in like two
years i haven't seen you since before
the apocalypse
yeah yeah
yeah
so uh for those out there who haven't
heard of you or seen any of the stuff
you've made could you give us just like
a little intro as to
i guess who you are i'm terrible at this
um
i mean i can take a shot if you want
yeah why don't you take a shot could you
yeah yeah yeah he'll do it so
addy i guess
i will give my like interpretation of
like my understanding of you and then
i'll give like the more general audience
version
but i've always understood you to be
someone who's out there trying to make
movies films shows etc media
but trying to find a way to make the
stuff that you want to make in a world
where it's controlled mostly by you know
focus groups and you know money with
strings attached and all that kind of
stuff conglomerates that just kind of
happen here yeah it's the studio game
it's totally big hollywood right right
um
but you've actually managed to
successfully pull some projects off um
projects that people probably have heard
of like dread is a fantastic film i
really enjoyed it um the gray the
castlevania series on netflix
uh
probably even more that aren't coming to
mind off the top of my head right now
maybe the short films like the bootleg
yeah that's right of course of course
the power rangers one the punisher one
yeah um which are all amazing
uh
truth in journalism there was a dark mr
rogers one a dark pokemon oh right right
right yeah the dark mr rogers one is my
favorite
um
but you're kind of like back when we
started doing chord or digital yes and
we were doing like our short films
mostly just inspired by video games you
were basically doing the same thing but
bigger and like in the actual kind of
like hollywood sphere you're getting you
know actual name actors to kind of come
into the short films
and but you had kind of like the same
idea of like i just want to do this yes
and then you're just doing it right
which is so rare to find out there with
people who are actually making it crazy
for me because
like you were the first person i met
that was like
i i was like wow you you're like me
yeah but
what was uh interesting i guess weird
when we first met
i mean remember i had like an office i
would like a studio deal i was like
making like
hollywood studio movies and like i like
didn't want to be doing it i didn't
i was like uh
but you know i somehow i
fell into this situation where all of a
sudden i was like in the hollywood
machine
and uh i was inspired by what
uh you were doing well thank you i you
know like i
like when i did the first punisher uh
fan film which was uh 2012 so i planted
in 2011 we pulled it off in uh 2012 and
i guess for
uh the people listening who have no idea
what this is it was thomas jane who
played the punisher in the 2004
lionsgate punisher movie
kind of reply reprising his role um
ron perlman uh
you might know as hellboy and just kind
of a litany of other things he
he was in it uh as well but i didn't
make it for youtube like i didn't i
didn't know what youtube was right like
i didn't understand that you could just
open a youtube account and then
upload stuff like i thought like you
know i was like oh this is more
bureaucratic red tape like
um
so
we we made it
um
and then
i didn't know what to do with it
and
yeah what do you do with like a high-end
short film based on an ip that isn't
necessarily yours like
yeah and i didn't really care just
wanted to get it out there and i'd seen
the machinima
logo i'm also technologically illiterate
right
so i saw the machinima logo and i'm like
oh i should get in touch with them
and so i talked to someone at machinima
and i'd said hey i made this thing you
know do you want it i i
and
the person i talked to didn't know uh
who the punisher was or
oh really yeah yeah yeah so i was like
oh this is weird
maybe
maybe this thing i've made just like
really stupid
and then uh this random person i met
just one day like random was like you
should open a youtube channel and i'm
like
i'm like yeah there's gonna be like a
lot of red tape like i just don't wanna
deal with like corporations and
and they're like
dude it's like a click of a button like
if you have gmail you can just open a
youtube page and i'm like
okay
so then i did and just uploaded it and
then it got like
millions of views in like a few hours
yeah no one else is doing that kind of
stuff you know it was a it was like oh
holy crap somebody actually like with a
good camera and good actors and a good
crew
and good post went out and actually made
a really cool short film and like that
wasn't really a thing
that was happening on youtube
yeah it was it was it was nuts and to me
uh i didn't realize that hey there was a
youtube community i didn't realize any
of this stuff
um
i was just like
whoa there's like an online distribution
platform where you don't have to ask ask
permission
that's amazing like yeah because i was
so used to dealing with international
distributors who are like well
cut this or move that or reshuffle this
or
cast this person in it and you're like
that's dude why would i cast that
channing tatum cannot play like a
british aristocrat like what the [ __ ]
you know but so much of movie making was
that before yeah before before uh the
digital revolution so to speak
it was like a litany of middle people
who were
um
forcing things to be things to resemble
things that came before it
yeah it makes sense
yeah
i mean it's still there's still a lot of
that i mean you see a lot of that with
uh you know with all like the youtube
red and i guess a lot of the shows
happening like amazon prime and netflix
where they're just hiring all the old tv
people
where it's like
everybody kind of moved to those
platforms because they didn't want to
watch the old tv format
and it's just kind of but it's just re
and they've just yeah exactly yeah it
it's it's weird i miscalculated that
piece
yeah because i remember coming to me
like nico
sit down
i wanted to tell you something
you're the future we should actually we
should preface that like you and i like
about once every one to two years we
have a like a deep conversation about
the state of the industry right and like
there's insights that you've given me
that like have stuck with me forever
with these conversations
yeah i remember like you were the future
one but the one thing that stands out to
me is like you were talking about how
like you just want to figure out a way
to be able to make the movies and the
shows
that you saw that you know you're
passionate about without the incredible
burden that takes to make them happen
you know because yeah currently it costs
millions and millions of dollars to do
the big films like how do you get to the
point where you can just make them
because you want to like
a writer can sit down and just start
writing you know all they need is a i
mean i don't even need a computer right
pencil and paper
so there's no there's no barrier to
entry there it's just your creativity
and you get to just go and create you
know same thing with drawing but if you
want to make a movie there is a barrier
to entry you know and like that barrier
gets lower every single year and i think
that's a lot of what's inspired our
career and what's inspired your career
is seeing this change like trying to get
ahead of that and like utilize it
yeah yeah the democratization of
art creation of art like the like just
just the tools um
and like the distribution of it
you know i
i have to believe that future
generations
will create things that are just
completely new and completely original
and almost feel like new mediums and
they'll be able to do it because of
the things you're doing right you're
kind of you're paving the way
for the next generation or next
generations
in the way that
um the indie filmmakers of the 80s and
90s
forced the art form to
evolve just like the indie filmmakers of
the of the 70s
kind of looked at how the movie studios
back then were just making musicals
they're making like these [ __ ] robin
hood musicals and like no one cared
and then these these renegade filmmakers
came in and they just disrupted
everything and they made
a litany of movies like
basically all the classics everything
that we consider a classic today yeah
even something like the godfather right
that was that was like a rebellious
movie back in the day it wasn't like
this
um
something that like the system or this
the
the system was necessarily
uh behind right
yeah a rosemary's baby um same thing
like that was kind of an outside the box
um what do you think what do you think
the
i mean
there's a whole bunch to talk about here
and i'm just going to jump right to the
right to the future because i'd love to
talk about the past a little bit too but
what do you think you know right now we
have we have youtube which kind of
started off as a place for people to
just upload their cool videos and it was
a small community and the community grew
and then it shifted heavily into games
and then shifted heavily after vine went
down and it's continuing to shift
heavily and of course now there's you
know a ton of celebrities have youtube
channels you have a bunch of big media
companies youtube channels the
the trending page is dominated by
tonight shows you know it's no longer
necessarily individual creators
sometimes it is
um a lot of the creators are famous are
really just famous because they're
personalities it's basically just fancy
reality tv in many ways and it's not all
bad but there's a lot of things i've
seen
kind of pop up over the time here but
what do you see
going forwards into the future what do
you see as like
avenues for
people to get out there and like make
their art again to make films or stories
and media
how do you think it's going to shift i
mean i think it's it's it's tough
i think it's tough because the walls
have come up again i think that's the
subtext of what you're saying right like
you and i were doing this
in an era
where you're like i want to make stuff
and get it out there and these film
school people feel pretentious that's
that was your experience right yep uh my
experience was i'm in the hollywood
ecosystem
i i don't understand what these people
are talking about i'm gonna go off and
like do this thing
and there were no adults there were no
rules
um
you know now youtube is it's regulated
it's heavily regulated i'm not trying to
get political about it because there is
that uh
discussion also but it's regulated to
the extent that like
um we're talking about one of the
biggest most significant most powerful
conglomerates in the history
of the world
um
you know what i mean like this is not
this isn't what we thought it was in
2011 let me put it that way
yeah or 2012 in my case
that's very true i mean youtube gets i
think it's like 2 billion views a month
or something like that uh unique views
if i'm not mistaken i mean google has
all our data yeah you know if they
want to start blackmailing
everyone they can
and there's no
legislative body that literally has the
power to tell them not to
look i don't want to go to conspiracy
theory because that's
just it just is what it is but yeah
um
i i do think that this speaks to
systemic problems
um that plague the distribution of
subversive art
if you were trying to make some versus
art these days how would you go about
releasing it me yeah like me personally
yeah like if i was like starting over
again today
i don't know because i feel like so much
of
who i am as an artist is a byproduct of
like the 90s growing up in the 90s right
so if i was coming of age today i think
my reference points would just be so
different like i wouldn't be trying to
do the same thing i probably wouldn't
even be like a
film person i'd probably be like an
indie uh video game developer
that's probably how i do it yeah
interesting cause you can make an indie
video game with like four people
yeah and release it on steam right and
the gaming industry is not and it's
coming but the gaming industry is not
regulated the same way that
uh
and not gate kept in the same
manner that
tv and film is
right because you don't have like
for instance
i mean i i can give you like a litany of
examples of
how this is true but but another aspect
of it is like you don't have
like video game
designers and developers from like the
90s coming and telling like
you know you don't have like a guy from
the 90s or a company from the 90s being
like well super hot it's technically not
a game
right but in movies you have like guys
like scorsese well that's not that's not
cinema and you're like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about dude like go away
you know what i mean
yeah like
that's not cinema like what are you
taught
but you know you have you have like
ideological gatekeeping as well as like
practical gatekeeping right like as in
you can't
get this out there
practical gatekeeping and ideological
gatekeeping where it's like
this isn't the thing that you say it is
and we are the authoritative body that
is the
uh
that that gets to define what this
medium is and where it's yeah where it's
going yeah you know it's like the thing
i always think about with that is
you know they talk about well the
algorithm drives things i mean you know
everybody likes to talk about the
algorithm and abstract you know it's not
that abstract
he just no i think the algorithm is like
incredibly practical yeah it is it's
it's practical but then like you know
the algorithm makes certain things
popular or not makes them popular but it
fine it discovers what people are into
and then decides to serve them more of
that right
um but for companies like whether it's
google or facebook anybody for any of
them to act like they don't have control
over that it's like well you know i
guess i made i guess it made jake paul
popular
you know
it's like
you can just
turn that off you can just change
the parameters totally at any point in
time you can just go in there back and
demonetize you know and i think also
sometimes calling it an algorithm uh is
used to obfuscate what it actually is
because it's not really an algorithm yet
it's more of an incentive structure yeah
right it's an incentive structure
funnel
right and these are choices that are
being made yeah because you have the
whole monetary side of it right you know
where it's like it's the whole almost
casino rpg where it's like you're trying
to get more points and you do this and
you get more points and yeah you get
dollars back
yeah i mean like they want the clicks
just as much as like
the person making the content
to get the clicks wants the clicks
yeah right because it's a big symbiotic
like a lot of times like corporate
entities like act like oh my god click
bait's ruining our art form it's like
dude you want the click bait because you
can game the click bait you can't game
like what you do can't be gamed
right yeah and i think ultimately this
is why you are the future because
what you do
cannot be gamed
you know when you look at most content
out there and i'm going to call it
content because it's just content you
look at most content out on the internet
on youtube right
since the
call it the corporate
conglomerate wave of control
when i sound like a [ __ ] conspiracy
theorist i'm really not
like
since that corporate wave came in and
and and kind of washed away a lot of the
small
smaller independently minded uh creators
um
a lot of the things that seem to
garner attention and uh ride the wave of
this algorithm
are things that are easily uh
kind of without an identity right so
they're and they're easily uh replica
replicatable i feel like the hydraulic
press channel is like a perfect example
you know or like
you know satisfying like we're cutting
clay with a knife like that's almost
just like raw content you know it's like
there's no
person necessarily like our personality
or figure
right it's not storytelling i'm not
saying that it's like you know sometimes
it's fun watching somebody cut clay with
a knife but it's like it's more that
you know that stuff can get 30 million
views
per video right versus like somebody
going out there and like telling a story
are you aware though that you're telling
a meta story on top of the mini story
but within each video
elaborate okay
so
when people sign up to corridor digital
sure there might be like a fun minecraft
video or a nerf video or like a john
wick
video or oh wow you know i'm seeing that
thing
but really what they're subconsciously
also signing up for
is the sam and nico story
like how we make our way through the
industry in our yeah career i mean your
art form has evolved right like i like
remember showing me that zombie video
you did yeah but way back when it was
like a zombie yeah zombie matador was
yeah yeah
um it was like in the snow and like
oh that one the daisy the daisy one yeah
like
you're evolving as people
and filmmakers like in real time
that's why it's not replicatable
because your story is your story
interesting
yeah and your evolution is your
evolution
and that that's real
that's like real right like you and sham
just picked up a camera and we're like
[ __ ] it we're going to make something we
don't quite know what we're doing but
we're going to learn and figure out as
we go along and then like people
have followed millions of people have
followed your
your your your journey um i mean i'm not
saying millions in like the abstract
sense like literally like how many
millions of subscribers are there on
your channel like nine uh nine million
on corridor and basically five million
on quarter crew
so
you know
assuming uh a deal of overlap there
that's millions of people that are like
following your journey as a filmmaker
yeah which is really crazy when you put
it out there
because you know you still come to work
and
you know
every day sit down the computer and
grind out some edits and record some
segments and yeah but like the people
who like designed the first engines
like they were like in a workshop like
designing an engine they went to work
every day and they went home and they
were like talking to their families
they're like oh yeah ned's out building
like a thing
i had no idea that what they were really
doing was building something that would
one day like
lead to
air travel and then like space travel
and then like intergalactic
travel right like the people who like
change the world and
create innovations that
then the ripple effects of those
innovations
uh
are felt throughout
the corridors of history like they don't
realize that that's what they're doing
because they do what you do you get up
and you show up and you like build a
team and you're having a good time doing
it
um well not always a good time doing it
sometimes these people like to end up
being abusive but like you're not that
guy you know what i mean yeah people are
like yeah i work for that guy man he
threw a thing at me
he threw the first engine prototype at
me
you know um
yeah like
guys today's episode is brought to you
by storyblocks the one-stop shop for all
your stock asset needs for creators and
businesses alike now stop and think
about that for a second where else on
the internet are you going to get a
virtually unlimited library of high
quality 4k b-roll images audio assets
motion graphics after effects templates
and more and then still be able to use
it in any kind of project that you want
now this is why storyblocks is so good
we use them all the time over here at
corridor digital through their unlimited
all access plan we can get royalty free
anything meaning that we can download as
much as we want from the site and use it
in whatever kind of projects we want
whether that's a youtube video for us
whether that's a commercial project
whether it's a project for a client we
can use their assets in those projects
however wherever and guess what if
you're part of a team talk to your team
leader about an enterprise plan that
will get you and your entire team
integrated with storyblocks so you guys
can use it too so head on over to
storybox.comcast or click the link in
the description below that's
storyblocks.com quartercast so huge
thanks to them for sponsoring once again
they keep this podcast going in light of
that fact let's get back to the podcast
yeah
you so like
you've obviously
been very aware of like how
media and the space of like consuming it
has evolved
could you could you give me your the the
adi shankar version of like the past 10
years of youtube and the eras that
you've seen it go through maybe not just
youtube but like
consuming media like what are the the
big the big shifts that stood out to you
so i don't know anything about youtube
because i don't go on youtube all the
youtube information i get is from you
okay right like remember when you guys
you and sam came over to my uh old place
like on that rooftop and you guys sat
there and you explained to me how like
nerf videos were like a thing yeah like
you should do a nerf video and i like
was like oh wow i didn't
like
um
in terms of like
call it the mainstream content which is
like tv film
and then it's pivot into streaming
i can i can address that
and i feel like there was a major
delineation
between the three at least when i
started off in in in film like so
there was uh within the film ecosystem
you had studio movies
this was like disney warner brothers
universal sony
releasing
uh movies that around so again we're
going 10 10 years so 2011.
this was mainly
60 million to 200 million
movies that were tent polls like so big
blockbusters
um
and ten years ago studios still took
risks with
things that weren't that
so things like comedies even uh
you know like seth rogen making movies
for sony and universal sometimes judd
apatow
um
that
went away
over time so
movies that weren't
pretty much a singular thing which is
like an like a giant spectacle
action adventure
franchise franchise-based
um
spectacle they just didn't work
so studios had to like stop making
movies for like 60 million 60 million
dollars they just they all became
all blockbusters they all became
blockbusters right yeah and even like
weird tonal things so you couldn't
really have like
um
horror comedies for instance right like
horror movies did well
comedies did okay but if you like kind
of merge the genres they like just never
worked they always went straight to
straight to vod best case scenario
straight to radio worst case scenario
now when you say never work is that just
because there just isn't an audience for
those things or is it just because no
one committed to actually trying to make
a good one uh
so i did make a good one i i would argue
it's called the voices
have you seen this movie i've not seen
the voices uh it stars ryan reynolds
uh anna kendrick
i'm in it as well oh yeah yeah yeah i
mean i had like braces installed and i
like
spoke with my indian accent
uh directed by marjon satrapi who's like
a
fantastic artist she uh she
wrote a comic book called persepolis or
scott turned into an animated movie that
was nominated for the oscars
um
sorry i just plugged something randomly
as an aside
but horricalis don't work for three
reasons
one
um if you one
the united states
is less than accounts for less than
of a movie's
revenue especially in the independent
sphere yeah right
um so internationally comedies don't
work
yeah it makes sense because there's so
many like cultural references language
and yeah so
horror movies do fine
action movies do amazing
comedies don't so the more you infuse it
with
comedy the less
uh well it's going to do internationally
i'm talking about like
the straight distribution model right
like going to theaters
vod rentals that kind of thing again the
streaming thing changed it all together
which i can get into
um
so back in 2011 you had the big studio
system and then you also had like the
the the independent model that was still
working right so this was
small distributors
all over the world um
who were
looper is an independent movie i didn't
know that yeah it was put together
independently through distribution
contracts piecemealed together
uh and made so they're like kind of
scrapping together the cash to make this
movie
um yeah i mean a lot of kind of
seminal movies from that period were
actually independent movies that were
made outside of the studio system
so even like magic mike that was an
independent movie mm-hmm
interesting um
drive
independent movie
wasn't the first teenage mutant ninja
turtles movie an independent movie yes
but again we're going back 90s but yeah
it was it was totally
um
and i think the big and then obviously
tv was its was its own was its own beast
right you had like the hbo side of tv
and then you had like everything else
um
i think the biggest
i have
seen
over the last decade within the the
apparatus that governs
the production and distribution of
content
is uh streaming has completely rewritten
all the rules right because
as great as it has been it's also put a
lot of those independent distributors
out of business
those little guys that were
competing with
warner brothers to try to
get
why is that why would why would
streaming put them out of business
because
um
so let's say you have uh
an independent action movie that you've
put together right it's you and you and
uh
you and sam are
gonna direct it and it's gonna star
christian bale holy moly okay
right
um ten years ago what i would have said
is like hey dude what you got to do is
go to go to like
the american film market or can
uh and
sell this movie pre-sell it to these
independent distributors
and they'll give you the cash and then
you kind of scrape it together and then
get your movie out there you can get it
made and then get it you know
distributed and premiered at a film
festival and
i'm going like very inside baseball here
it's great i love it this is i love
inside basically yeah you do okay
um
the problem is
those are exclusive contracts right
so when you like netflix is not
a us thing it's an international thing
it's a worldwide thing right so when you
do a deal with netflix it's a worldwide
deal
yeah
they don't want those strings attached
right of like limitations with various
territories and things yeah that they
just
they're like we want it
day and date
released worldwide
so if you have a contract with like
uh
you know metropolitan in france which is
like the big independent distributor in
france um
they want you to not have that deal
yeah
so you're kind of stuck basically you
sell to netflix
or you commit to having to get
everything from independent
contributors
yes
and then or you could do something you
know kind of odd like or not odd like um
there are some movies still that like
where it'll be on netflix in the u.s but
internationally it's not
right uh but the irishman is a good
example of this uh there's this that um
like the the the irishman was was pieced
together through this model okay and
then netflix came in and just was like
dude get rid of all these international
distribution deals like what the [ __ ]
and then it became a netflix movie so
this pressure from you know streaming
platforms like netflix to pull people
just to make one big deal has basically
kind of taken away
the life support of these independent
distributors and basically dried up yes
and also
it's changed the value of content
right so if you go back to like 2004
your first run would be the theater
right
the theater
would do something
worst case scenario best case scenario
it's a giant hit and everyone's happy
worst case scenario it proves to be
marketing for the dvd
and there was an entire like life cycle
for a movie because you could like kind
of look at a movie as almost like an
asset
i sound like a [ __ ] business guy you
are a business guy am i yeah i i feel
like i'm more of a crazy artist
yeah but you're you're doing it still
and that means you had to make a
business out of it i really have not
made a business out of it what i've done
is i i can explain how the business
works but i don't follow any of this
[ __ ]
um
i'm more of like a student of the game
so i like understand so i've i've like
studied film history
and then i was like well this is
interesting how did it evolve the way it
evolved and then i like studied the
business of film and then you see how
they kind of worked part and parcel
together and they uh
to create
uh the ecosystem we we exist in right
well i think i think you've always
understood the importance of
understanding the environment you're
trying to put a product out into if you
don't get to control the means of
distribution yourself
you
know and like
i'm obsessed with understanding how
things work and why they work the way
they work and how did the thing become
the way
it is
because
you know yeah sure it evolves by by
chance but there is a lineage to
yeah you got there to how it got there
exactly um
what was i just saying before i just
interrupted myself i'm not a [ __ ]
business guy we're talking about the uh
movies like an asset and you had a whole
life cycle you could go through right
sure so exactly so the movie had an
entire life cycle that it could go
through um so it goes you know uh
theater dvd paid tv free tv vod and i
was just kind of going through
through this entire life cycle
uh now it just kind of is almost one and
done with streaming
hmm
is that like is that does that mean
there's less money yeah
okay so movies are worth less so it's
kind of like so i said it's a it's an
asset so imagine it's a house
right
so imagine uh 20 years ago
there were 10 ways to monetize a house
right like you could you could rent it
out you could
use it as a showroom you could use it
sure also there was like something below
the house that
was generating minerals that you could
sell uh you could also use it as a
garden to grow fruits and like and every
house followed
this
this model and then all of a sudden uh
the internet comes in
and goes okay there's one way to
monetize it now
and that's it
so every piece of content is now worth
less
so what does this how's this affected
your approach to making stuff then
oh it hasn't at all okay yeah it hasn't
affected me at all because i
i'd
but i feel like because
because of that you only have like one
way
of making something well here's
something it's helped me actually yeah
it's helped me it really helped me did
all these things have helped me
tremendously
oh
because
there was a business machine
that existed that allowed
that governed what got made and didn't
get made and how it got made and
how much it should cost and
what everyone got paid it kind of
there was a machine behind it and the
machine
what i'm really trying to say is the
machine was falling apart
before
the streaming war started
and then the streaming wars started
really showing the cracks in the machine
and then the pandemic just completely it
was like it was like stallone coming in
with a knife
you know and like
so
um
do you think theaters are dead
no no no no no i think the the theaters
are dead to the extent like so i want to
differentiate between the theaters as in
like the theatrical experience like
actually the theatrical experience not
what filmmakers call the theatrical
experience where you're like what the
[ __ ] is this experience like the popcorn
sucks like there's someone talking like
parking's a nightmare i mean like the
actual act of going to a big screen and
the communal aspect of it
versus the business model which is like
amc and
these conglomerates
that
um
have
made the theatrical experience what it
is
which is basically shuttling people in
and out of these
dark rooms
you know
yeah i don't think the theatrical
experience is dead in fact i think the
death of amc is going to allow it to
evolve the way it should have evolved 10
years ago interesting right because
these things need to actually be an
experience right it can't just be
christopher nolan being like the
theatrical experience is sacred it's
like
okay i guess but like they're doing a
really bad
job of it right like yeah it's like i do
enjoy watching the dark knight
at my home
also
but imagine uh you know and there was
legislation going back decades ago um
that prevented movie studios from owning
theaters that's right in the in the us
it's not like that everywhere like so in
korea the entire film ecosystem is
vertically integrated we're talking
about like one company will own the
theaters make the content manage the
talent
develop the develop the material
and the theatrical experience has not
gone away in korea like people
korea is a uh well south korea i don't
know about north korea i haven't been
there i can't speak to it um
um
but the theatrically just has like a
banging like 200 million marvel
competitor that we've never seen because
it's like completely locked in the
country totally
and this is made specifically for um
for for mr just mr moon mr mr i was
going to say mr ill but no it's mr um
now
um
so
what was i saying
south korea has vertically yeah they
vertically integrated all and
um
the theater thing is still a thing there
it never
there's no debate like oh is it gonna be
is it gonna come back like it's been a
thing and it
doesn't stop being a thing
um
but i think once the
i seem really anti-conglomerate i maybe
i am um but once the conglomerates go
out of business
their business model will have to change
and
now that the law has been repealed oh
really that
doesn't allow movie studios to own
theaters
um
you know i could see
someone like disney coming in
and starting their own theater chain i
feel like it's just like extra premium
disney plus it's like yeah i'm going to
the disney i mean they make
experiences right that's what we're
doing in parks they also created cruises
it's not hard to imagine a theater it's
not really even a theater anymore it's a
full experience that you go in to
experience a bunch of stuff and then you
go watch the next avengers movie
and the whole thing is a curated
thing it's not would you like some
popcorn
you know like it's a
it's a it's a full thing uh um and i
could see amazon doing a bit pulling a
similar move like
the point is the movie theater
is going to evolve into
something else
and we'll look back
as old people and go oh yeah that used
to be a movie theater
the
business model around it and the fact
that movie studios
and the theater owners which
kind of they operated like the theater
owners they operated like a cartel
it's weird they're like you know
they had an ungodly amount of power yeah
that's what no one's talking about like
it it's not like the theatrical
experience has
gone away because of the internet it's
like the the this
geriatric ward of
man i'm literally burning bridges uh
i just kind of kept it from
they kept it stagnant they kept it from
evolving right because it was all about
like how do we increase our profit
margins right
let me ask you a question hit me
um
[Music]
you're disney okay
you make an iron man movie
you put it in a theater
the movie makes one dollar of crap
what percentage of that one dollar
does the theater keep and what
percentage of the one dollar comes to
you if it only makes one dollar just
period one dollar hypothetically my
recollection is that the theater keeps
half of it yes
that's that's crazy yeah like if you
made a shoe and you put the shoe in
nordstrom nordstrom doesn't keep half of
the shoe
[Laughter]
right
that makes sense
so
you know when i when i when i look at
the history of the film business
so much of it because of how complicated
and costly it is to make art
um
there's been a litany of middle people
that have made it more and more
difficult
to
make things outside the box
because of
you know all these people taking a cut
so everything just becomes more and more
risky yeah i mean if theaters are taking
half like let's say let's say you do a
200 million dollar marvel movie like you
need to pull in 400 million right there
just to actually make your budget back
but then there's marketing which is also
a chunk so now you're hitting
600 million before you're breaking more
totally yeah and that's why when you go
back to 2011 2012 and you're like why
did they all become blockbusters like
why did movie genres just [ __ ] go
away right when you look back at like
classics from our childhood like back to
the future would that get made no [ __ ]
no that would not get made would the
goonies get made no [ __ ] no because it's
like
kids you know like anything kind of like
a little offbeat yeah went away
yeah um and it went away because of this
because you're like okay if you're
making something and you're minimum
having to spend 40 million dollars to
market it more likely
north of 100 and then this and then this
and this and this it forces
uh everybody
to start homogenizing what they're doing
because you can't take risks at that
point don't actors also have like
requirements like you're gonna spend
this much money marketing with my face
attached to it and stuff like that not
really no just a few people had bad back
in the day not really and really the
other big trend uh that i've experienced
is actors movie stars
have gone away uh and
have lost clout i've noticed that too
like
it's been like kind of a nose dive like
a free fall
yeah i feel like brad pitt george
clooney tom cruise
like i feel like that's the end of the
movie star era
to some extent like you know you have
younger actors but i mean heck even now
like marvel films
maybe only 10
of like the actual population of the
country 15
actually know who iron man is or thor or
captain america or even said you know
robert downey jr plays they'd be like uh
batman
you know like if you got beyond that but
like we feel like there's such big
cultural things versus like
40 years ago like when movies came out
they were cultural touchstones where
everybody knew about it because there's
only one avenue versus so many these
days
yeah
i mean i could
so
like 40 years ago
um
movies didn't get international
distribution
with the level of efficiency that they
do today
so
you're speaking with a little bit of
selection bias as an american oh yeah
you're right
right it didn't occur to me yeah
um
because you just couldn't get everything
into every country like yeah countries
had like
blockades that's right were they like
there's a lot of like cultural
protections around totally too what you
could and couldn't show like
so again there's a there's a selection
bias but also there's just to your point
uh so much
media
just just straight up media
that every piece of it becomes less
important
but as a whole
it's having a greater impact than ever
before interesting so every piece of it
matters less but as a whole it's more
influential than it's ever been yeah
this is one of the things i noticed with
like films coming out on netflix versus
like when a movie like
we're we're pretty close to the same age
if not the same age
35 36 so yeah yeah i turn 36 next month
i've asked you this so many times yeah
but we grew up in a very like i think i
mean i think it was the golden age of
movies at least as we knew as we know
movies you know as the late 80s and 90s
that's nostalgia dude you think so yeah
i just i feel like the way
is like i feel like at that point they
had kind of refined the art form and
perfected it from the previous 30 to 40
to 50 years
and kind of really had dialed it into
something that you know was would really
hit hard emotionally
and then the way the market was
supporting it was it with all the money
that was going into it and how
culturally relevant they were
i just feel like there's a lot of big
stuff getting made and there's still big
things getting made but yeah the
observation that i've seen now is like
when you have say a movie that hits
netflix
in about one month it's off the front
page and it's completely forgotten
whereas
you know if a movie came out and you
went to
blockbuster video to go rent it like
that movie would be on the shelves and
you'd walk by it year after year after
year and you know granted the crappy
movies that no one remembers sure fall
away sure
at the same time i'm not i don't
necessarily disagree with what you're
saying but again there's there's a
degree of selection bias here going on
there's one
um
there was just fewer movies period right
so
you know it's not like titanic came out
and then all of a sudden you have like
40 other boat movies that are competing
with it you know yeah um
and that's that's a big one there's just
more content
there's just more stuff
uh two
i don't feel like
the art form of filmmaking like the
people who do it
and it's going to happen right they'll
be a
someone who truly breaks out from the
digital age but no one's quite figured
out
the streaming of it all um like how to
make something that like resonates with
with a streaming audience in a way that
creates that back to the future
right kind of
uh which is seminal yeah just like
harmonizes with like a part of your life
right yeah no one's quite figured that
out and it's because of what you were
saying earlier which is
hey these streaming platforms they they
started like this they expanded rapidly
and then they needed to fill the the
content vacuum uh the endless content
vacuum so they went and hired the for
the most part like the old
the old tv film people right the people
that were making like nbc shows and yeah
law order and
that that kind of thing um but it'll be
people not even our age i think it's
people younger like the tick tock
generation that come in and create
something that like you're like you know
where scorsese gets really mad he's like
this is not cinema and like people are
like who are you again
you know and then it's like i met the
irish fans like oh right one video on
that movie with the really bad deep fake
um
it wasn't a deep fake damn it um
so
yeah i think
and
also if you talk to people that were
like
seminal filmmakers of the 90s
they were sitting there having the same
conversation you and i are having about
how much better it was in the 70s
where they gonna grow up right because
in the 70s like the independents were
truly independent
the studios had just given up because
their ship was not working
and it wasn't until the 80s when um
corporate america came in and started
acquiring hollywood
so they were complaining about the
corporatization of hollywood right so
all these seminal movies that affected
us
were all the corporate corporate
corporate products right i mean et is a
corporate product like uh spielberg and
lucas like they are innovators in
corporate filmmaking they created the
blueprint
that
lasted for 30 30 plus years
of corporate filmmaking
like how do you make something that
touches you emotionally doesn't offend
you know
again that's not a knock that they again
innovators right
yeah but it was
we're looking at it with rose colors
colored glasses because that's our
childhood right that's the experience
that we had and here's the thing i'm
saying all this to say that
the next generation the seminal things
that influence them are not netflix
streaming shows it's your stuff
it's your stuff like literally they're
watching you and your journey as a
filmmaker and the videos you put out and
they're like i want to do that
that's interesting you know i i met uh i
think i was mentioning this to you
um outside
i made a friend in dubai
abdullah
who religiously follows you guy he like
loves you i'm going to connect you guys
via via email because he's a great
very good very good dude um
much younger than me much younger than
us
but he was talking about you
not not even knowing that we were
friends that we are friends okay he was
talking about you with the same level of
reverence
that someone from our
age demographic would talk about
james cameron or you know like a like a
seminal filmmaker who made
uh seminal content right um and i think
our selection bias tends to be for our
age group it's like okay if it's 90
minutes that it's real art if it's two
you know
but that's again that's selection bias
yeah because
we are judging
what we make
against the
and using
the past that we grew up in as a litmus
test to judge the present
but the past literally doesn't exist in
the 90s does not exist
so
you are a seminal filmmaker of today
well i appreciate you saying that
that makes me feel good
and i'm just you know a guy who
pontificates
[Laughter]
pontius
that's cool you know there's one
pontification that you had that like
blew my mind and it's obvious now when
you look back at it but it was that
shift that happened when vine went belly
up yes and how that totally changed
youtube and the space that at least that
sam and i were in right you know and the
rest of the quarter team at the time
you know went from because youtube was
very filmmaker-centric for a while
totally and then suddenly became
you know personality personality's not
quite the right term because i mean we
had personalities
driven yeah
where it's like
it was all like the characters from
reality tv shows realizing that they
didn't need to have a crappily edited
reality tv show to get people to pay
attention to how loud they were right
and that like totally shifted the focus
away from
i think to a certain not completely but
it shifted the focus away from creating
something to
being something and filming yourself
doing it right
and like when you pointed out that shift
and how when vine went down and all the
viners moved over to youtube it entirely
shifted the youtube ecosystem the
algorithm wasn't ready for it that they
had neon place and something that's that
is what youtube became and then still
it's still i don't want to say struggles
it's not quite the right word but it
still struggles with that identity a
little bit
and trying to evolve out of it
interesting i don't feel like it
struggles at all i feel like you know
their what does their slogan broadcast
yourself yeah oh they embraced it 100 i
think this is
they went this is what we are right
because look
um
i mean there was like you you guys right
clinton
uh who who works here worked here
uh
freddie freddie wong
there were a few people out there making
art now did the mainstream
media
view it as art i don't know
i viewed it as art right
that shit's gone
like you're left standing because you
built a business around
what you were doing
and the business thrives right and that
business
kind of operates in a vacuum away from
the
tyranny of
the youtube incentive structure yeah or
algorithm
um
but if you're a corporate entity and
again i don't want to sound like a
conspiracy
kind of anti-corporate guy but if you're
a corporate entity
it's kind of safer
to have these personalities running
around
how so
um
it's not that special
it's special to the extent that like
it does take inertia to get up and
vlog and film yourself and come up with
antics and build so it's not it's not
without um difficulty
but anyone can do it
as long as you're you got the
personality for it exactly
and the tools
to
uh capture it
right and the tools are readily
available to become more dem they become
more democratically available every day
as you're finding out as we're all
finding out yeah
what you
do um
it's a little more nuanced
that makes sense right but
i think what what's been really like
incredible about
what you guys have built
is i think i mentioned this to you as a
negative i'm like oh like this [ __ ]
thing you guys went off and went like
yeah like let's turn our entire uh
engine into a reality show
and that it became a key driver
of of uh audience retention for you
mm-hmm
i i literally sound like i have a
[ __ ] like like a business degree
right i don't know what are you doing to
me dude
like
key driver of audience retention
like i don't even know what that means
but it makes sense when i say it out
loud right um
uh
yeah
[ __ ]
um but
those are the insights that you always
have you downplayed you've always had
like a very good insight into like
the game you know it's the game around
all these times because i mean at the
end of the day like the rules of the
game are simple
you know it's at least the rules as i
understand is
make something
good to yourself at least it doesn't
need to be you know
good is very subjective but do your best
try to make a point with something try
to make it special try to make people
feel something okay right go out there
and try to make art
and then
make sure there's a way for people to
access it and you gotta get their
attention to look at it
but beyond that that's it those are the
rules of the game go out there make
something put it out there make sure
people can notice it and let them notice
it and then just keep doing it you know
it's not about doing it once and be like
that was it
you know wipe my hands it's not about
spending six and a half years doing it
you know making one thing for six and a
half years while your buddy makes an
entire uh
media conglomerate which we'll get into
that in a second
but yeah you know it's just you just you
have to be okay with doing it every day
right and you just have to be true to
yourself to some extent and
and that's it you know those are the
rules of the game
but
you know you talk about like building
building something that's a little bit
different than the rest on youtube and
like not to take the spotlight away from
the guest on our podcast but i do want
to talk about that for just a second
um
because there is you know
observing my friends that have been in
youtube but also just like other
youtubers and you know the business
people on youtube
i think the one thing that like
there's a couple things that we strive
to do
with corridor
priority wise that i think
made it so we could be a little bit of
that outlier
and that was
you know first one is building a good
team and having a team of artists that
you know
you respect but they're also you
acknowledge that they are
they are individuals in and of
themselves with their own strengths and
their own powers and you know
the things that make them special and
you know when they when they when you
join up as a team it's so that person
can do what they do best yeah so you're
like voltron not like rita repulsa like
you know sending in minions don't have a
mind of their own they get their ass
kicked yeah yep and at any point what
that does it takes all the pressure off
of you well not all the pressure but
takes a lot of pressure off yeah because
something fails somewhere somebody has
an issue like the rest of the team is
independently strong and can like keep
lifting this entity right
you know the other thing that we
really try to focus on was not like
everybody in the tech world grows really
big first and they worry about profits
second and instead we tried to worry
about profits from day one where it's
like you make 10 bucks spend five make
20 bucks spend 10. it's like don't spend
more money than you have
don't grow faster than you are growing
just one step at a time in a couple
years you'll get there but just one step
at a time
and so we try to be just very careful so
that we're never in a spot where we're
getting pinched and we're never having
to chase profits you know because like
we grow so fast okay every now we gotta
make some money like that wasn't how we
ever had to operate right
uh and then the third one was like to
never just never forget why you're doing
it in the first place
you know i didn't start making videos
because i wanted to make money you know
obviously i want to make a living making
my videos but i'm not here to get rich
right i'm here to make videos and as
long as i have enough money to live and
support myself and
have a comfortable lifestyle that's all
i need
and then i'm cool going out there making
videos with the rest of it right and
like i think that speaks to a truth in
in the art that you pursue it's like
totally if you know if you could make
you know let's say you're making a
hundred grand a year's your salary and
you could go out and you could make you
know 10 million dollars a year with your
salary but you had to make
kids videos you know you have to make
kids cartoons
and you know sorry like let's pretend
that you you hate making kids cartoons
right because obviously there's people
out there who are great with kids i'm
not trying to rig on them let's pretend
you hate making kids cartoons some of
them are creepy but sure
[Laughter]
like i really just want to make kids
cartoons and uh that's my dream
like those guys
you know and some people would be like
yeah screw it let's go do it you know
i'm like i'm just gonna grind it out for
a couple years and i'm retired and
that'll be my thing whereas like our our
direction was like nah let's just keep
doing the things we want to do and even
in the years where youtube's like not
rewarding that's like it's cool let's
just keep doing the things you want to
do because that's why we're here and
those years will pass new years will
come
and i think that's really
i think this really kept us from burning
out it's kept us happy and you know it's
i think it's the reason why we're still
here 10 years down the line totally we
had a we're doing a little talk with
like one of our
youtube uh people
that helps us kind of like analyze
things
and when the the conversation started
they had they've been looking at the
corridor channel um
because they didn't know where to
quarter crew channel yet they just come
in on the like oh okay corridor that's
your main that's your channel let's take
a look at like
it's a really strange channel for
youtube it's uh you guys only upload
like four times a year
but you have like nine million
subscribers um you don't have any
personality stuff you don't do any live
streams you don't have any subscriptions
you don't have any i'm like yeah that's
because the channel is just where we put
our short films that we're passionate
about yeah and that's what we've been
doing for a decade you know yeah yeah
um yes let's talk about stockholm don't
chase trends
right
i'm aware of that you're totally aware
of the trends which is brilliant right
like like like the time you were like
hey man nerf videos are in and i'm like
right
i had a whole idea for like an ultra
violent nerf video and i just didn't
make it like
um but yeah you don't try to chase
trends
and you're not making widgets
right
which you know um
a friend of mine
you know i have like a lot of like
really like old men old old old men as
friends right we've talked about this
yep
so one of my one of my my friends uh he
passed away earlier this year
innovator
and he produced an album for the beatles
right so this is how how how
wow
so he's he's old school yeah
um
one of the first things he piece of
advice he told me which is just exactly
what you said he's like
you know if you're going to make widgets
and widgets are just kind of basic
instruments to
that are just something basic like go
make something basic don't do this if
you're going to do this
do what you're passionate about and
that's what you do yeah
you know and i think
when you explained the profit thing to
me
i was like
holy [ __ ] you're totally
right i was doing a similar thing on a
different
wavelength right because
in my experience um
filmmakers are so eager to get that
blockbuster it's like man can you
imagine what will happen if i get 200
million dollars to make a movie and
you're like
yes i can imagine you won't get 200
million dollars to make a movie you will
get a committee making a movie that you
are like the scapegoat for that's what
um
but yeah when you said that i was like
me and this dude are
that's when i knew we would be kind of
friends for a very very long time
because i was like we are totally on the
same wavelength and you also once
explained to me how you
were
had grown in dealing with your editors
in-house
and how you got really good at like it's
kind of a nuance between
explaining what you want but also giving
them the creative freedom to to to do
that but not letting that become because
that's a boundary thing right because at
a certain point there's like it's a
balancing act because you don't want
people just kind of like
[ __ ] on your vision but also kind of
getting their stuff in also right
when you explain that to me i think
we're at uh cafe gratitude that's right
uh i was like
oh
holy [ __ ]
because like
i'm not great at communicating sometimes
actually a lot of times i'm like [ __ ]
terrible at communicating or i used to
be
gotten better nice like i couldn't have
done this podcast like i don't know two
years ago
it takes practice
and a lot of there was something weird
going on with like my mind mouth
connection where i like
used to take like really long pauses and
i still probably do but yeah
i also just wasn't comfortable with how
i looked
how did you approach that like how did
you
how did you
reflect on that and then on row from it
from which part both like both like you
know trying to become a better
communicator but also becoming more
comfortable with just who you are and
how you look and all that
oh am i making an assumption when i say
you're more comfortable
no no i am okay i am
[Music]
so i i didn't really
have a lot of
i mean i had self-awareness in some
degree but then in some ways like i had
zero self-awareness
right
so like
i think i mentioned like i'm friends
with a lot of like professional athletes
and and wrestlers and stuff like that
and
i didn't understand that i'm kind of
like a pixar character i'm like kind of
a nerd
kind of like i don't understand i'm kind
of like a funny person you know
like i thought i was supposed to be like
stone cold okay
stone cold steve austin or stone cold
steve okay
right yeah i like i didn't get it and it
was actually um do you guys do you know
who diamond dallas pages yeah i'm a huge
fan gdp once was like bro
you
literally don't [ __ ] see
yourself
you have no idea who the [ __ ] you are
and once you figure it out
watch out hmm and i'm like what is he
talking man i didn't know he was so wise
dude ddp is like super wise he's like
that's why me and him are like
like
homies he's like very wise that's super
cool he's like a
like a
yoda like figure and also um
kanye west remember when i was hank when
i was
that window when i was me and kanye
would hang out remember that
kanye really helped me with it yeah yeah
kanye helped me like i mean i grew leaps
and bounds just
just from his advice and what was his
advice for you
um
so the
there's a few things like so one was um
[Music]
so you know like i wear face paint and i
run around right and i'm playing a
character i'm being authentic right now
because we're friends but
i was like uncomfortable
being myself because i didn't know who i
was necessarily and you know i moved
around every
two to two and a half years as a kid so
when you're like a little kid moving
between not just different cities but
different countries different
civilizations right like
by the time i was uh
like 13 i'd lived in like
eight different places different
languages and stuff like that so
everything just feels very confusing and
discombobulated uh
to you and you develop this kind of this
pattern
where you're constantly people pleasing
because you because you have to
assimilate very quickly
so it makes you a little kind of think
but when i would wear the makeup
i would play a character kind of like a
wrestler
would
and
i felt very comfortable in the character
because i knew who the character was
uh
so
he sat me down kanye and was like you're
playing a character like me
like kanye west is a character
and
um
you know i never had an adult say that
kind of break it down for me like that
before right
yeah so that was that was just huge just
being able to kind of like
talk intellectually with someone really
about what was going on for me which was
i was i was so scared to be myself i had
to be this other thing
because i didn't know if i'd be accepted
as me because i i probably subcon not
probably i subconsciously didn't accept
me
because i you know i didn't look like
the people around me i didn't talk like
the people around me i had different
uh
different world views than people around
me that was a byproduct of just being
from all these different places
um
so that was super helpful and then the
craziest
i guess the craziest thing was uh
and the whole this whole thing was was
super surreal so
i had a really bad time in high school
because and i was living in hong kong
hong kong got handed over uh it was part
of great britain then got handed over to
china
junior year my parents moved me to a to
a to a school in rhode island so it was
like super preppy i went there i moved
to america by myself when i was 16. oh
wow
uh and then two days later 911 happened
oh man
and i was like the only person that
looked like me
in the vicinity right
i don't know
so uh i didn't have a good time in high
school but this was i i i didn't you
know
i didn't know why i'm just like
i remember having a really bad time in
high school
um a lot of like anger and resentment
as well
um and then we had our 15-year reunion
coming up
so this is like yeah a few years ago
15-year reunion
and um
i got an email from the school saying
hey are you coming to the reunion
because we'd love to have you talk to
the students
about your work and
stuff like that so like
acknowledgement's cool
my first reaction though was like this
is like get out
this is all a ploy
you know what i mean yeah this is gonna
be some [ __ ] thing and i got like
kind of douchey about it
to be perfectly honest but i didn't know
right
so
um so i said yes right so i
go to this reunion which ended up being
amazing it was an awesome experience i
realized how much
of
this narrative i created around this
place was just a narrative given where i
was emotionally at that point in time
because of
you know leaving again going to another
eco going to another country another
community
just very dissimilar for my own
it wasn't like international the way i
was it was used to it was very kind of
small town
and homogenous
and i wasn't part of the
homogenous amoeba so i felt even more
like an outcast
and i got to talk to the kids about that
which was really really interesting
right
and i saw the
just that the faculty was
it was it was it was bizarre because it
felt like i was in a movie
or a tv show about a guy right because i
don't
it was it was so
it was crazy because i was like
literally going to this place that i'd
like built a narrative around
and everyone's just happy to see me
they're like happy i was there
you know what i mean yeah they were like
oh man it's so amazing that you're back
like and i hadn't stepped foot on this
campus since the day i graduated
and so as i'm on stage speaking
uh kanye called me
and this was the week that
uh he had that famous meltdown where he
went on tmz and said a bunch of stuff
and everyone was mad at him
so he called me to talk about that
because he was like
you know
uh so i'm like looking at my phone and
i'm like guys i just one sec i need to
go talk to it to a friend
and then uh i finished my talk went
outside sat on the floor called him back
and we had this
whole conversation
where
i thought he was calling to ask
i don't know what like like my thoughts
on what the the the whole thing happened
and that
that tmz meltdown and whatnot
but really he just was like asking me
about how the high school reunion was
like
and i'm like
yeah so it's okay yeah it's good good
and then he starts yelling at me he's
like you are not in touch with your
feelings
you're in your head and i'm like what
and i'm like what is this [ __ ] guy
talking about
and then i found out at the end of the
year he was absolutely right like i
think i had so much
trauma as a kid from moving and like you
know you make a friend
and then you move like when you're when
you're five years old or three or
seven or nine it's goodbye forever it's
traumatic goodbye forever there's no
internet you're not gonna see these
people again
so i had the i was like emotionally very
disconnected from my entire life
uh and that made it hard for me to
uh talk because i was intellectualizing
everything
hmm
i told this whole kindness but it was
like very very insightful right because
like
no one had said that to me that directly
before right because
um
if anything
i was praised for my intellect
like you know in in school in college
post thing like the opportunities i got
uh right off the bat to make work on
like these big studio movies and just do
it always came because i was saying
quote smart
stuff so you're always being rewarded
for being emotionally disconnected and
completely in my head
i didn't know to the point where i
didn't know
that there was another way to exist
that's really i mean i think it's really
fascinating stuff and i appreciate you
sharing that story you know it's high
school like not to take too big of
attention just on high school that's one
of those things that like you're in it
and it's the biggest deal in the world
right like high school is the most
important thing to you when you are in
high school right
and then like within a couple years once
you're at high school like oh
that's just a blip in my life it's just
a moment
you know for people it can be very like
formative but still it's like looking
back on it now it's like let's just say
a three to four year stretch
out of you know
so many three to four year stretches
and it does not like define you i don't
have that experience
yeah yeah
because schooling for me was very
consistent
as in if you're there for two years you
go to the same place that repetition the
people around right
like um
i feel divorced of community as an adult
because
everything's constantly changing the
world's changing
uh
i mean think of like how many
new words society
has invented in the last five years it's
more than the last thousand years before
it right yeah
so things are changing at such a rapid
pace um
to me school is is a callback to a
simpler time
of consistency of repetition
sounds like you're sorry i was gonna say
it's also the only time you're ever
forced
to be in the same building
with literally
everybody
in the population at the same age as you
i mean obviously within a certain radius
but like
there's not another moment in your life
where you will be with every other
person that lives in your city or your
town that's your age and so you're
forced to be with everybody yes
i also didn't understand that like
people in the school thought i was
cool
yeah i didn't get it because i because i
you know i was like
i just kind of like corner people and
you know
um
i'd be like you what did you think of me
when i like how did you perceive me
the thing and they would tell me i'm
like what the [ __ ] that's like not how i
thought anyone perceived me
yeah i think so but i think that's so
much of of of your childhood is like
your mental state casting a shadow
and making like these these sweeping
assumptions or at least if you're an
artist like making these sweeping
assumptions on how
things work yeah and they don't
necessarily
like reality distortion amongst young
people
has to be a thing because at least it
was for me i'm sure i'm sure it's even
worse now when you have
and we live we now live in a world where
you have two personas you have your
online persona and your offline persona
you know your real you and the presented
you
right so
you know it's probably
that whole reality distortion thing's
probably even worse than it was back
when we didn't have any smartphones
we're gonna part your or your pub g
persona or a pub g persona or a
fortnight yeah
if you like the dance my twitch persona
yeah
so
taking a little turn here to a different
conversation you've been working on a
project for about six and a half years
yeah we even helped you out a little bit
with it not even a little dude you're a
second you're a [ __ ] second unit
director man heck yeah thanks to addy
here uh yeah no it uh was actually
in large part inspired by uh the work
you were doing um
you know i was inspired by uh
i mean the list of people that it's that
that kind of inspired this
is
is kind of eclectic because it's like
john carpenter paul verhoeven oliver
stone
nico
look at that company
uh you laugh because you don't see how
innovative you are oh man
um but you are in that you are in that
pantheon of of great filmmakers
um yeah six and a half [ __ ] years man
uh i didn't under yeah
guardians of
justice guardians of justice
how openly can we talk about this
well we i mean i guess it's it premiered
it can uh
well a few hours ago oh hey yeah damn so
it literally premiered at [ __ ] or
canned series which is the series
iteration of can
which is crazy yep it's crazy because um
i mean it's not a superhero show it uses
superheroes as a motif uh i didn't want
to make a superhero show i wanted to
make um
something else um
but uh
it's crazy because
you know can is very
off seem this is seemingly very
off-brand for cannes
yeah you usually think of like wes
anderson movies when you think of ken
like dramas about people losing cats or
not even losing cats like you know just
just like kind of deep emotional like
this is my life as a 60 year old who
likes wine you know i was like right
that kind of thing and you win awards
and like
and i'm like what the [ __ ] were in canon
the artistic director uh wrote like
the kindest thing
uh about the about the the series um
yeah the reception's been crazy good um
which is weird because i spent years
um well one judging myself and two
feeling judged and three probably being
judged yeah you know and they get every
judge they're like dude this guy went
off the [ __ ] rails man
in his twenties he was like doing movies
with brad pitt and now and his [ __ ]
what the
yeah you know so so guardians of justice
you know i i'm gonna take a shot at
describing it and then you should
actually describe it after i take my
weird shot
but
i feel like it's a culmination of the
bootleg universe idea which you've
i think it's been something that's stuck
with you for a long time yes um i think
it's that's one of those things where
it's like that's a bug that's going to
be nibbling at you forever yeah um in
the bootleg universe i feel like to back
up there
is you wanting to
as a filmmaker and as an artist you
wanting to
add to this world
of cultural icons or even just like
mythological icons at this point that
define the stories that we know you know
it's like
like luke skywalker right it's a
mythological figure to me and like if
i'm gonna tell stories part of this can
be inspired by luke skywalker in fact i
might even want a luke skywalker-like
character but we live in this weird
world with like ip
and copyrights you can't just have luke
skywalker being your thing um and so
guardians of justice is kind of your way
to
take a lot of these motifs things that
inspired you
uh the different characters the the
style of stories that surround this and
be able to step into this world and kind
of quickly get past some of these basics
that you'd have to deal with otherwise
and then get to start playing playing
with these building blocks and doing new
interesting things with them
is that accurate kind of it's it's
accurate um
i feel like there's a
i feel like that's accurate uh totally
accurate and a fair way to describe it
um
if you're a fan of me
and haven't just been introduced to me
as a result of
this podcast
it's a slight pivot from
my previous stuff and i think it'll
cause all of it to be viewed in a
different light
because um
and i think
on some level i realized what i was
doing with the bootleg universe right
because i wasn't trying to do accurate
interpretations of power rangers it's
like i actively loved the show as a kid
and i realized like
when i watched blood diamond like oh
this is the same story it's like
here they're like
you know weaponizing kids and giving
them guns and they're they're
weaponizing kids
it's like the same [ __ ] so you know um
[Music]
and i realized like as an outsider i
have like this outsider's perspective
because i am
a perpetual outsider having grown up in
not one place and not one cis society
not one community
um
so it's it's it's that outsider
perspective i love how i'm playing with
my hair out of nervousness when i talk
about it um
and i think like the big
thing about this project is it's
you know i
you remember the movie the wizard
fred savage that the one that the
nintendo power glove it's like a
nintendo commercial but like
yep so i watched that when i was like
six
okay in hong kong
and i was like
where's this movie set
i need to go there
and they're like oh it's in america and
i'm like
oh my god i like
literally would go to sleep every day
and like pray to go to america huh
because i was like oh my god i want to
go to america i tell my parents like
when can we go to america there's this
place called america and my parents like
yeah we we know what it is we're aware
and then i got to go to america
got to come to la
um and and see it and it didn't
disappoint i mean when you when i like
turned on the tv it was like amazing you
had like you know
pro wrestling you had all cartoons and
amazing toy commercials and like pizza
houses where they had like [ __ ]
arcade machines and
everything was super violent but they
were like marketing it to kids which is
awesome
and
it was like so this project
is me taking all those
experiences of how i viewed america as a
kid
and
kind of transmuting it into
a project which is why it took so long
because like because
um and also
um
this is kind of weird but my memory
plays out in animation well really yeah
that is interesting it's weird i didn't
realize that this was unique to me or
i'm sure it's not unique to me i'm sure
other people are like this too
but i had no idea that this was not the
norm
until i asked someone like
it
and
so the project is like it's kind of
would you say it has a kind of a crazy
pacing and a crazy yeah yeah yeah not in
a bad way not crazy isn't like i can't
follow but crazy in the sense that like
oh here's somebody that's entirely not
worrying about conventions and it's just
going to tell you the story and get to
the point you know yeah um so the show
is how i see the world and that's kind
of what like being in my head is like
okay
is that do you think that's why it took
so long it's just because you had to
trying to
personally speaking like trying to
articulate things that are ethereal
blobs in your mind usually takes a
couple tries before you even get
anywhere close to what you're actually
going for and i lacked the vocabulary to
explain what i was trying to do
i i literally did not have the the
sentences to say hey this is what i'm
trying to do like remember when i showed
you guy like a few years ago i showed
you guys something
and uh
and
sam was like oh this is interesting
you're using abstract entity i'm like
what what was that what you said and i
like made a note and i'm like i want
abstract editing
like still no one knew what that meant
but
um
but it's like until i had a
something to actively
show that was final
you're just kind of like what the [ __ ]
is this yeah
and
like it's just not a superhero show and
i think that's the kind of the joke of
it
um
because there are people who worked on
it who literally think oh i worked on
this superhero show
and they're gonna watch and be like
ew
yeah so why would you not define it as a
superhero show
i mean you got superheroes in it it's a
superhero show right
it's not about superheroes
it's it's like people dressed as
superheroes
but that's about it
that's about it i mean there is a kind
of a superhero
storyline in it
that just ends very quickly it's just
it's just it's just not it's
um
you know the
i think thematically the inspiration
was uh
stanley kubrick's dr strangelove oh
interesting
you know um
and like i didn't know how to explain
again lacking the vocabulary like i
didn't know how to explain to the people
who were working on it
like they thought that they were working
on a
live-action
dark dramatic series right
but i needed everyone to believe that
because that's how you get the
performances right you you get what i'm
saying here because you've seen it like
the the tonal yeah you need i mean if
you want actors to like give you dark
serious performances you need to tell
them that's a dark and serious place
like no this is this is there's actually
a meta commentary on like this like no
you lose your actors yeah no one got the
like i didn't tell anyone that they're
actually in a comedy like a in a in a
satirical kind of farcical comedy
um
so i was almost like pushing them to the
point of overacting
because i was like look the more you
overact
the better this will
uh
the better this will read yeah
um especially with now like how stylized
and fast-paced and just like
in your face isn't quite the right term
i'm going to use it in your face it is
like
you need that bigger acting for it to
even stand out at all right yeah because
i mean i would what i didn't have the
the vocabulary to explain to anybody
who's working on this is like you all
think that you're working on a live
action
series
which you are
but it's not a live action series this
is a saturday morning cartoon that turns
into live action not the other way
around you know what i mean yeah
yeah that's a great way to describe it
so it was almost like i was working on
four different things
i was working on four different projects
that i knew at the end would kind of
converge into one
one thing
but i needed them to kind of all operate
independently of one another yeah
um
because i knew hey this piece is gonna
be this this piece is gonna be that
this piece is going to be like funny
this is going to be done and then
when we bridge them when we but but
again like
um
no one really knew what i was doing
until like a right at the end hmm and
then uh and then we got into can and
everyone's like
[Laughter]
that's super cool like
first off you know staying with sling
for six and a half years to get it done
that's an achievement it takes a lot of
fortitude to make something like that
happen
yeah
yeah yeah it definitely it definitely
did um
you know it was it was like
i think there was like kind of a meta
aspect of it as well
where it's like
um
i didn't want to just make something
conventional
right
because
i know how the movie ecosystem works i
knew how that apparatus worked if i
needed to game it
i knew how to game it right what you do
is you make an action i
i knew what those steps looked like
right i wanted to really challenge
myself
um because i wanted to know what my
limits were
um
i was
this is going to sound a little
egomaniacal
but like in my 20s i kind of just had
success
you know and it was like kind of wild
success it wasn't like normal
yeah you're making big you're making big
hollywood movies it was [ __ ] crazy
because people are doing that no and i'm
like a dream of like so many people
right and i just showed up here and i
was doing it
yeah
and then like um
and then like i was like okay i want to
really want to like kind of stretch
myself uh and learn what my limits were
and then then i reached the breaking
point with this because i'm like oh this
is my limit okay i need
i i need i need some of it back like
i don't like i really like you know i
think the project like definitely gave
me gray hairs uh and
um
probably a bunch of health problems um
but uh
yeah it was just it was it was so
challenging and also
also
um
i think
it was like a year and a half in
i was like
i don't have the vocabulary the
knowledge the skill set
the personality to get this done
like i'm like i just don't
i was self-aware enough to know that i
don't like i don't have the tools to get
this done yeah
and at that point i was like okay
so
you should either like kind of pack your
bags and just be right cool i don't
or
become the guy
that you need to become to get this done
oh that's the way to go right yeah and i
knew that like okay there's there's like
weird um emotional hang-ups that i have
and like core limiting beliefs
and uh uh self-sabotaging tendencies and
whatever the [ __ ] they are i need to
look at them stare them down uh say bye
to them cut the cord with them to become
the guy that can finish this thing
or just not finish it
right and then so i committed to like
the self-growth aspect
in order to like become the thing i i'd
say it's more than more like a couple
years a couple years in um
and then yeah and then it slowly so the
project transformed me as well you know
um like i needed to
change as a human being i needed to
to grow you know like crack under
pressure grow through adversity
uh
you know diamonds are only created under
pressure it's like whatever that
cliche is
i'm sounding like a motivational speaker
right now but
yeah this necessitated
a lot um also
there were a lot of helpers along the
way
right and i'm not i'm not talking about
the crew and the team
that ultimately assembled to help me get
this across the finish line right
because once you know your strengths and
weaknesses as you pointed out then you
know okay i can do this
piece of the puzzle but i probably
shouldn't and someone else and then
you're like oh you you want to do it
cool
so um
there was like a whole voltron thing
that assembled around me to help this
across the
nice the finish line uh
at some point
you've met a couple of them actually
over uh you've met a couple of them
like you've met graham for instance yeah
graham graham is one of the the voltron
guys
do you feel like this piece do you feel
like guardians of justice kind of
is a little bit of your meta story at
least in this phase like this later
phase of your filmmaking career
absolutely 1 000
you know the crazy thing is the only
reason i did castlevania
was to learn how to do animation so i
could finish this really yeah
nice like it's funny when when there's
like this
sometimes people are like man do you
feel proud of castle i'm like dude that
was like a side project so i could learn
a skill to do this
that's a story of like every corridor
video it's like oh it was actually an
experiment or we needed to learn how to
do this one effect and it's like so we
just made a video around it right
yeah um you know learning how to direct
in
eight different mediums which is the
shows in eight different like that was
like a
that's crazy that's crazy yeah and
having like not done it before that was
that was that was uh
yeah that was an ordeal it wasn't film
school it was the most intense film
school you can have um
so it would play that at can
is it is it up to be bought or is it
already no no so it's it's it's uh it's
for netflix so okay so i did this this
for uh for netflix and it was uh
there's an executive there named larry
tanz
who um it's just i mean
at this point you might as well be a be
a father figure to me
at least it feels that way i don't know
if that feels that way to him
um
you know he he was a supporter of
me and this project and just a champion
of the whole thing and
literally pulled me aside a few times
and i was talking earlier about
helpers
and i derailed myself but and i'm seeing
not just helpers in the crew level
and the team who made it level but
like
uh and larry is one of those people
because
you know i nearly gave up in
2017.
i kind of had a shitty version of it
done
that i was just like all right [ __ ] it
let's get this off
and he called me up and he was like
he was like you know it seems like
you're trying to say something here with
this
is this really what you want to put out
and he's like i just want you to know
like you know you you've just done
castlevania and it it it's
done very very well
critically and you know numbers-wise
like there's gonna be attention on what
you do next
so this
if this is it great
and i was like no this is not it
ah it takes guts for him to say that
yes
well yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean look
again different
just an amazing man like larry tanz is a
freaking like amazing amazing man like
he should be
i don't know what he should or shouldn't
i i don't want to be an arbiter of that
but he's just an amazing dude and i
think you know a lot of
uh filmmakers in the past that we kind
of we revere
there's always an executive there that
just believed in them championed them
supported them
um
my mom also said the same thing which
was really interesting
because there was someone who worked on
uh an aspect of the project who came
over
uh to my place and was like you need to
get this out this needs to get out like
all these people wanted out like
and i'm like yeah i was feeling kind of
bad i'm like yeah you know all these
people who like
wanted out and then my mom was like
why is this guy like
it's kind of selfish i'm like what do
you mean she's like
like you're clearly trying to make
something
unorthodox you have a vision here
the jew doesn't care about your vision
getting out there he wants this out so
that his resume checks the thing you
know can check off the resume and jump
on to the next thing she's like don't
work with this guy and i'm like
wow
thanks mom
um
and i i'd say this to be like you know
one of the things one of the emotional
hurdles that i had to
conquer
was constantly apologizing for my
existence you know um
there is a lot of bravado i have you
know again the makeup the
talking trash in inter you know that but
some of it's real some of it was just
insecurity it is in security and some of
it's just me [ __ ] around because i
think it's funny right and i wanted to
secretly be a professional wrestler and
i like
i love the performative aspect right
like it's why i like was just like
dissing scorsese at the beginning like
normal people don't do that they're not
like um
but um
but yeah like i had to kind of grow past
this apologizing for my existence
apologizing for my point of view
apologizing for being different
um thing
and again this is something that kanye
helped me with as well
uh
because he was like playing me
a song
from
his
album from the new album not uh the the
not this one um so this is a few years
ago this is the previous one
this was here when he was like yeah i'm
gonna drop four albums one a week for
four weeks this is like
this
and um so he was playing me a song like
explaining to me how he made it
um
and again i i can't you know people have
their
perspectives and opinions and and they
are what they are but but to me kanye is
like a like just an amazing person she's
an amazing person
uh just a just a great human being um
and a fantastic
artist
and
he was explaining to me part of his
creative process where he used paul
mccartney in a song
but like paul mccartney listened to the
song and he's like where the where i'm
not in the song and he's like no i use
part of your voice and like remix you
know what i mean
and i thought about it and i was like
wait hold on
if paul mccartney
if i'd like kind of shot a thing with
paul mccartney
i'd want to do the same thing i'd want
to like [ __ ] up his image and that's
what i do with the blue legs right
because it's me taking the thing and
[ __ ] it up i have this instinct to
take something re kind of consume it and
regurgitate it into something completely
different
and then the moment i get challenged a
little bit from a corporate entity
boom i'm there i'm fighting back right
but the moment it becomes like an
interpersonal challenge
then i just kind of i would like cower
i'd be like oh i don't want to hurt this
person's feelings
i've been so fortunate i was almost had
like too much gratitude for the success
i had in my 20s
just felt bad like you know i'm like i
don't want to hurt someone's feelings
the whole thing
and
i don't know when we had this
this whole conversation i remember the
next thing i did
is i emailed you
asked you for some footage
went to the editing room
and
cut that that commercial that we just
you know it's like what using your first
person shooter
yeah footage like ultimate gun game
video right yeah and i cut this
commercial together with with the
announcer and like the whole thing and
people were like what the [ __ ] is this
and i'm like this is what i'm trying to
make hmm i was like the rest of it is
gonna be like this hmm
that's awesome and that's why i keep
saying every time we talk i'm like dude
you are a big part of this process
well thanks man
i remember when we first met is that
comic con yeah and we played we had that
dark uh dark link video or whatever link
shadow um
and you're like yo this is sweet
i was like oh you're eddie shankar
and the rest was history
yeah
yeah that was
that was a
fun convention yeah that was a good
comic-con
that's my first one i've only gone like
two and a half times since
do you remember there was like a dude
dressed as deadpool
in the crowd do you remember this
vaguely
this is like before deadpool was a thing
right right right and i think you and i
kept being like
deadpool's gonna be you know we can't
remember i have this vivid memory of a
deadpool dude with signs like kind of
holding up a sign
um
i don't know why i'm remembering that
but it was it was um
who else was on that panel it was like
and it was like moderated by a guy from
machinima right
i don't remember wait uh
i feel like there's another guy that did
like a couple really cool shorts for
machinima
that's about all i remember there's like
that
i was gonna say that mortal kombat thing
but you did that didn't you no oh no
that was kevin tantra yeah okay i think
he was there yeah kevin was there yeah
i remember just being worried that like
people are gonna find our video too gory
and offensive
like even though it's not that gory but
also like all the [ __ ] just really
stands out when like you see it played
in front of a crowd it's like every
weird sound effect camera bump like
there's a shot that has like our camera
lens cases like on a rock i remember
being so insecure
um
and i was like
you know at this point i had my like my
company was making studio
stuff i think the only reason i was on
that panel was because someone at
machinima
found out that they're like wait this
guy made the punisher thing and he
offered it to us and someone said no
they were like what the [ __ ] they're
like so they called him and they're like
um it was jeremy jeremy jeremy jeremy
was like hey
uh next time you have something
let us know
i'm like oh i'm doing like a venom one
they're like what
we're in we'll show it the thing and i
was like so insecure to screen into this
crowd
um
i remember the venom thing now yeah
because i didn't go to the screening of
because we screened the punisher one at
comic-con i didn't go yeah it's the same
reason i didn't go to cannes like my
whole team is i can they're like you
know like i like i don't like showing up
to things because like i get um
i'm very sensitive
like i'm super sensitive so when there's
a lot of energy being thrown at me like
um
i get really excited and then my nerves
fry out
but i remember just being kind of a
douchebag before
that panel right and i was like yeah um
yo it's got to be only me on the panel
like who are these other dudes and like
um someone who worked for me at the time
was like um
there's gonna be more people there to
see corridor digital than they are
and i'm like
oh all right they're cool
and then i hit you up and then we like
met we had like lunch in my my old
office yeah
yeah the crazy old office and you've
basically been there like every time sam
and i were like we're gonna make a movie
and like we'd always come to you first
and be like
here's how it actually works here's how
the game's actually played and you'd be
like oh
okay
we're gonna think about this a little
bit then and then i'm always like
i will help you with this movie as soon
as the guardians of justice is done
that conversation was going on for six
and a half years
i'm like yo okay the moment this movie
is done the show is done
like we are making a series together or
a movie or something we're doing
something
now i have a child
yeah
another one on the way and you guys have
all like you know done things with your
lives and i've just finished this
this project
you've done more than that
well you know started a blood dragon tv
show working on devil may cry i'm also
psyched for that blood dragon tv show
wait definitely cry
yeah you know i'm doing double my cry
right yeah i just i'm just saying that
because i'm also excited for that yeah
um
when does guardians of justice come out
do you know um it will likely be top of
next year
sweet yeah um they want to like dub it
in some languages i love that you're
like
a person that
places like netflix are turning to now
for like video game properties
i don't know if you love that but i love
that
um
i don't know if they're turning to me
for video game properties oh really yeah
i think you're approaching them with
video game properties let me put it this
way i love that
if there's if video game properties are
getting turned into movies and shows or
whatever these days i love that you're
out there making it happen yeah for sure
for sure for sure no i i dig that also
um
again it feels like a huge blessing
because
i don't look at myself as a guy with
like
the secret sauce
or or anything like that
i think i think you have enough of a
perspective that makes like video games
are weird like for you know movies and
shows like that like taking those and
adapting them because you have so many
different weird pressures like you have
the corporate pressure of like hey we
make we publish this video game and you
need to tie it into how we sell our
games yeah so part of my strategy is the
moment they bring that energy to me i'm
like hey yo go [ __ ] yourself that's the
guy i strive to respond with a go [ __ ]
yourself i'm gonna walk
energy not in a disrespectful way right
right but like
um
how do i say this
i feel like it's a massive disservice to
everyone involved if i'm out there
making transmedia content right right
like i don't want to be making a
commercial for the game that's coming
out right
you want to make a piece of content that
isn't is what it is it's its own thing
it's its own story you know it's like
yeah i'm not i'm not watching these
movies i can go buy the action figure
i'm watching the movie because i want to
watch the movie
and i feel like that's where a lot of
companies and and game companies by the
way are super they what you just said
they're super on board it's like legacy
media hollywood companies that don't
[ __ ] get it
but game companies are super on board
with with with that right because they
understand their core business they're
like we are a game company
um so there's no corporate weirdness at
all
um
so i'm saying that with a bunch of like
yeah go [ __ ] you like they don't even
say that to me right like
capcom
is
awesome
that's good like
they're just like super supportive and
positive
um
[Music]
yeah i mean like all of them they all
they all are like they've literally
never brought that energy of corporate
pressure
like ever that's incredible i'm
surprised you haven't dealt with that at
all so let me let me ask you so when it
comes to video game franchises like
this is the thing i'm like super nerdy
and passionate about
um
you know you got two options i feel like
when you're making a video game movie
you have the option to either stay
really true to the source material sure
and bring in the fans the game and
maybe even capture the spark that the
game captured initially to bring in new
fans right
like where it's just like wow whatever
like like if you if you took metal gear
solid one and you just
you know basically took the game line
for line and shot it as a movie you
could potentially capture the magic that
you know captured people into that game
back then you know for people who would
see it now who are new but for the most
part you're just kind of catering to the
fans that already exist or you have the
option of reinventing it and trying
something new with the hope of bringing
in new fans but not necessarily catering
to the old fans
where do you lie on that spectrum
so
i don't think there is such a thing as a
video game adaptation
so i i don't even like engage like i
does that make sense okay like i'll give
you an example i'll give you an example
this like
mega man
dark souls
uh
command and conquer red alert right
all video games
but they're completely like like all
they share is this arbitrary
classification of being games like
there's literally nothing in common
between the three of them right
right
so
the way you would adapt one or engage
with one has no bearing on how you'd
adapt or engage with another right so
each
thing so i don't look at them as games i
look at them as things right
and each thing is radically different
because sometimes what you're doing or
what you could be doing
is
um expanding
the lore making something around
i'm gonna get to inside baseball here in
a confusing way so i'm gonna i'm gonna
just pivot
see i don't feel like there is a thing
as a video game adaptation
um and also as things get more and more
as life gets more and more gamified
i think as and as time goes on and
there's like everyone's a gamer
um i think it's
again i lack the vocabulary to like
really specifically precisely explain
what i'm what i'm trying to convey
mm-hmm
i don't think a video game adaptation
is
really a thing
so in the sense that like every game's
story is different so how you approach
it is different on a
different pantheons of lore and they all
have different
styles of gameplay and they all have
different like some of them are inspired
by movies some of them like you know
like look
as an example right
this isn't true but you've seen it so
i'm gonna i'm gonna okay tell me true or
false okay
guardians of justice
is also a mortal combat adaptation
true
yeah
see what i'm saying yeah that's what
you're saying
like
there's so many components to a game
versus like a book is simply a literary
it's literary so you're taking the
literature and adding visuals around it
right
games exist
uh in another kind of realm
yeah
and sometimes they're not even really
stories i mean sure there's a story but
there's like so much like weird nuance
that goes into it i mean yeah i made a
movie out of battle battleship
not a lot of story i mean now granted
it's not a video game it's not a whole
lot of story in that uh tabletop game
okay but i'll give you an example
like
you could make like a
christopher nolan style
grounded and gritty
metal gear
movie right
but like
part of what makes metal gear awesome
is the camp yeah yeah it's the weird
like sound design and the exclamation
marks over people's heads and in snake
going like huh you know yeah
yeah right so
um
like you're not you can't just translate
the story i mean you can you can't and
that's the that's the beauty of it there
are no rules
so i try to approach everything with
like my own
artistic
uh stamp integrity right um
and
and i guess game game people understand
this intuitively games that work
they don't work by accident
right like electronic arts
is like they're not accidentally
continuing to be one of the biggest
companies making games but they make
games but they make like corporate games
right that's just why electronic arts
like do they really make like kind of
hit
like emotionally resident hit
emotionally resonant hits
once in a while but not that often right
yeah like they're batting averages like
their indie studio will put out
something that actually has a cool
storyline yeah but their batting average
is kind of low right yeah for the big
games
yeah the biggest it's battlefield it's a
multiplayer thing and you have but you
go back to like blizzard before it was a
conglomerate right when black one they
only made three games and that was it
yeah and you know it was just starcraft
warcraft diablo yeah like every title
was a hit right because this was like a
passionate group of artists getting
together to like make something that
deeply care about like if you look at
like the uh halo 1 and halo halo halo 2
it was the same thing it was like a
group of passionate individuals not
unlike corridor
or out there just making a piece of art
then it clicks
right and i think
part of the the complexity with
corporate life the corporate system the
corporate world
is you get people in a garage or in a
warehouse like yours or
in a small studio somewhere
and they're throwing things against the
wall and then something sticks
right and then they get
obsessed with it and they have to get it
done it's like
like an auteur filmmaker
like
any great inventor from back in the day
from the history books they they get it
done
and it creates shock waves and ripple
effects that like [ __ ]
change everything
right um
and then the suits come in
and then they spent a lot of time trying
to reverse engineer like well how did
this chair that they threw
against the wall stick to the wall
was it like the tape they're like you
know they spent a lot of time and money
trying to reverse engineer why something
worked
and end up trying to replicate it
which is a fine way to go about life
right and that's how you get like
electronic arts
but the bottom line is it's stuck
yeah just keep throwing
different unique things against the wall
something else will stick yeah
reverse engineering the thing that's
stuck will just mean
that you get a clone of that at best
i feel that 100 in game media these days
right and movies all of it yeah all of
it it's all kind of the corporate
interest comes in and tries to reverse
engineer
and
the artist has already moved on to
version 7.0 while they're trying to
figure out how 1.0
happened yeah
um
how did we get on that
i don't know
it was a good tangent oh i was asking
you about like your approach to video
game movies but i think you you answered
that
perfectly yeah and game companies and so
i think game companies especially the
game companies that i'm uh working with
right so it would be
the ones that we publicly have been
announced which is ubisoft
um
capcom
crafton with pubg
um
they're
just forward thinking
in a way that like traditional legacy
media companies are just not
and i think part of the reason they're
so forward thinking
is traditional
media companies the legacy media
companies they've operated like coal
miners or like gold miners like a miners
right to the extent where they're like
they're like okay we make a product
so we're going to control the tools that
allow
us to make the product no one else can
make it
we control the distribution and the
marketing so no one else can if they
make the product somehow they can't get
it through our distribution channels
and will control the actors the movie
stars the marketing tools
that let the general public know that
this is worthwhile
so the legacy media companies like they
controlled
the entire process
top to bottom
for decades right this is why very few
movies made outside of the system even
got through
um
and if like one got through like my big
fat greek wedding it was like a big deal
right
um
and even like seminal movies that were
supposedly made outside the system
you're like wait that was made by like
the indie label of the studio right sony
pictures classics right
so
um
and then the studios worked kind of like
cartels right they were
there was a handful there were like six
of them and they worked together to be
like okay we are going to it's us
we are the the barons
uh we are the gatekeepers we are the
creators of global culture
and they were for the longest time right
game companies evolved very differently
and they evolved differently
because
they were basically tech companies
right and i think we big tech gets a lot
of
credit for this
but nintendo had personal computers in
people's homes
around the same time right yeah because
that's what it is it's just
yeah like nintendo created a handheld
mobile device before steve jobs even
yeah started the ipod right so
game companies are really tech companies
tech companies and
they're forced to innovate every year
it's about having cutting-edge
technology right movie studios legacy
media they didn't need to because they
controlled
the barriers to entry so no one could
compete with them
so they're like let's not innovate too
much let's not [ __ ] [ __ ] up right yeah
like the best innovations you have are
things like
3d
versus with game companies like they
have to innovate yeah and it wasn't as
simple as like oh we own this franchise
so it's gonna
you know we own
mission impossible or whatever franchise
and that's gonna result in people coming
and showing up like as we've seen from
medal of honor
like if you stop innovating great people
will move on to call of duty
yeah like overnight
so game companies are built on a
spinal structure
of innovation
right like ubisoft's been around since
the 1980s but the only reason they've
survived is because
on some level they had to keep
pushing yeah
and
so i think when you deal with game
companies a lot of times they're like
easier to deal with than legacy media
companies because
they're trying to figure out what's next
versus legacy media companies are afraid
of what's next because what's next is
extinction for them
you know yeah
yeah but if you don't change you're
going to go extinct right yeah and in a
way yeah
man it's always good talking to you
about this stuff because you always have
so much insight on it and like you said
you're not a business guy but you still
like your observations are always
just good to hear like it really makes
me feel comfortable about where we are
as a business
versus like i'm like man
it was so good i'm not working for the
studios like you know maybe it would be
cool
but just some more about you right um
um
like let's look at where we're likely
heading over the next 10 years
um
the trust in the
mainstream media has just completely
eroded and is eroding at an all-time
rapid right pace right
all these mainstream media outlets are
trying to move online
in order to capture an online base and
finding that they don't actually have an
audience
what they had on tv was a passive
audience okay right so like people watch
cnn on the background
when people watch a corridor video
they're
actively engaging it out they're
engaging with it right so it's a
different kind of engagement
the passive old media old world passive
engagement like oh i'm
browsing the the grocery store and i see
this magazine that tells me that
i have to watch this new hugh jackman
thing because he's the most important
person in the world
now is like
it doesn't work the same way online yeah
so the
it's not that people aren't being
marketed to they're just having to be
marketed too differently
online
yeah and
you have your own streaming platform
yeah
which is like when we started that i
remember mentioning it to you too it's
like
another streaming platform which is like
what a lot of people have been saying
but i think that's the direction we're
going as an industry is like yeah
you pay your three four five ten dollars
a month
to whatever platform you want to absorb
content from and then when you're
finished with it you can cancel and go
to somebody else
but also just the concept of stepping
away from ad supported media and getting
into like speaking with your money like
no this is what i want and i don't want
you to have to deal with ad companies to
make it you can just deal with me
it's the future yeah it's literally the
i think that's the future it's it's that
it's uh a decentralized media ecosystem
right so when i say mainstream media i
don't mean like
that it's a very like political term i
don't mean i don't mean it just in the
political sense like
there was a
monolith or a series of monoliths that
dictated what people in the world
consumed and when they consumed it and
how they consumed it and their narrative
around what they're watching
right yeah the monolith went this is
what a good movie looks like this is
what a bad movie looks like and i'm like
this is [ __ ] because like to me
knight at the roxbury is like one of the
greatest social satires i've ever seen
you know it's like really a
deconstruction of like
uh
the tribal myths around
well anyways uh
we'll do another podcast on that of the
roxbury night at the roxbury is a
[ __ ] classic it has like a 12 on
rotten tomatoes yeah so critics like rag
on it they rag on it because
it doesn't fit into the narrative of
what
is good right
and i think what people are finding
discovering more and more and more is
like hold up i have an individual taste
i'm an individual i have individual
preferences
i don't necessarily fit into
red or blue uh gray or this or this or
that
like these binary options that have been
presented to me as like a democracy are
really just binary options
yeah and
you're you're part of that wave dude
you're part of that wave because you're
giving people
a hyper specific
experience
that they
seek out emotionally engage with and
your end goal
isn't to
you know grow a 100x into a
it's not to do that right your whole
business model is like
sustainable growth yeah we just we just
want to make cool
videos and stories and the only way
we're going to do that is
with an audience that wants to see them
and then a direct connection between us
and the audience and you own your own
business yeah right so you don't have a
board of directors saying like
you listen kid
all right you grew you grew less this
year than you did last year all right
you got to grow a little faster can you
do a cat video okay
or uh
uh maybe make a [ __ ] sitcom okay kids
i [ __ ] love sitcoms let's make a
let's make a sitcom okay with guns
like
like you're not having that
like there's no like
overlord
trying to
push
a business metric
that ultimately is like a virus right
because the idea that you have to grow
more this year than you did last year
and you have to grow next year more than
you did two years ago that's that's like
it's like a virus yeah mindset yeah um
no one's [ __ ] forcing that [ __ ] down
your throat yeah so
this just becomes like a
artistic exercise
where you've built a
apparatus that allows you to
sustainably uh
exist in it not necessarily even grow it
just exist in it yeah and everything
about you has been [ __ ] organic dude
and that's that's
one of the many things i
respect about you
the organic produce section of youtube
you're like the whole foods of people
oh man i think this is the part where i
also need to give a massive shout out uh
and thank you to all the
quarterdigital.com subscribers because
they're the ones who are
enabling us to take that next step and
to do these transformations that you're
talking about and abdullah
and abdullah shout out to you too
[Laughter]
yeah
well it's been a wonderful conversation
with you it's been nice seeing you again
because i haven't actually seen you in
like two years yeah ever since the world
locked down
and i got this like
sick jacket
it is a sick jacket i like the green
color it's like i'm a biker dude right
now you could fall over and you'd get
back up and you wouldn't be scratching
totally
remember when you first asked me on the
podcast when you started remember what i
first said
call me up and you're like hey we're
starting a podcast we'll have to have
you on
and i said
i'm totally down
i look fat right now
so i'm gonna work out a little bit
and then i'd love to come on
right
right and i haven't worked out since
then so this is growth yeah this is
growth this is you going like you know
what screw everybody i'm just gonna go
on the most interesting thing about me
is not how i [ __ ] look
they're like that guy in the podcast did
you hear him do you hear how ripped he
sounded so [ __ ] chiseled like oh my
god i need to just like and subscribe to
that guy just you know
yeah for other people are audio only
they're like
cool
like i got people in like ireland
they're like oh my god i got the like
and subscribe
he looks so good not scottish
you're way better at accents than i am i
love doing you know what i'm doing in
america we've talked about this i'm
doing an american accent right now yeah
does that does that weird you out at all
like do you like do you realize you
don't have like an accent anymore
because you can just say you can speak
in whatever accent you want
are you like do you have like that
crisis of identity no
little bit
i think it's more annoying to people
like who who spend a lot of time around
me because i start like just talking to
them in different voices let me hear let
me hear just audi let me hear how you
talk to yourself in your head
dude it's crazy because it's like it's
like all the different they kind of all
merge right mm-hmm like hey how are you
doing like you know it's like well i'm
doing quite well right now i'm not quite
sure
i'm constantly having these like
conversations
with myself
um
yeah man but yeah like you know i think
at some point i will convert this accent
into like a more like snake pliskin
gruff dude
hey nico
good to see you bro i'm like hey hottie
it's dark out there
let me get you a flashlight yeah
[Laughter]
sweet yeah man dude uh thank you so much
for having me on
thanks so much fun thank you any
anything you like if people want to like
keep an eye out for guardians of justice
or like
follow anything you're making any any
spot they should go to or yeah they
should just subscribe to your uh
platform some more
um no um
just follow me on instagram yeah yeah or
facebook but really instagram what's
your instagram uh bootleg universe okay
so be posting like updates on guardians
and whatever else you're kind of doing
maybe yes just just random stuff i just
started posting on instagram um
and it's at bootleg universe because i
for a while i was like maybe i should
change my name to bootleg universe
like personally yeah like hey boot like
yo my name's bootleg universe
[ __ ] like yeah um
yeah i've thought about changing my name
i mean you could be mr universe
i feel like people would think i was a
bodybuilder or something and then yeah
they probably would get the body from
dysmorphia back oh yeah i mean they'd be
like
bro i thought you were going to be
ripped and jacked and frankly i can kick
your ass
so i'm not impressed
yeah
all right
well everybody thank you for listening
uh consider subscribing to the quarter
cast if you aren't and at bootleg
universe yeah follow and validate
universe validate me go say hey you're
awesome on the podcast thank you for
coming on yeah yeah and like my [ __ ]
all right man that's it we're signing
off bye everybody bye everybody